oh [__]
[Music]
five it's that type of night [__]
go tell your mother to check on you in
two hours because we're going deep
tonight if you're under 18 hang up now
you little [__] this it go do your
homework you [__] go blow balloons or
something like that
[Music]
oh [__]
look at this [__] monster coming at
you that's one type and look at this
scary [__] [__] here oh oh yeah
if young 18 hang up now
it's gonna be an ugly United what if
you're under 18 at heart what did you
know [__] you
the Lord deep tonight [__] the
same they'll Michael Jackson and this
ain't drilling I'm saying oh [__]
la Luna least favorite chocolate direct
from France English French sure very
fancy
we do everything a lot fancier little as
we were smoking plane and get [__]
stoned as [__] somebody's going
liability
Paul kisses ambulance what this
somebody's gonna [__] down to this
could be [__] foreign shore leave me
Molly should Pauly Shore never come back
[Music]
uncle Joey's back you guys are sitting
there we haven't seen you
we're back [__] and better than
up brush them at landing city water on
me I'm glowing in the [__] dark you
understand me tonight's your first night
welcome welcome to the experience that
is the Church of what's happening now if
you're under 18 hang up now [__]
get off this [__] internet because
you're a little [__] go get some
porn or something you little [__] anyway
it's gonna be a good show tonight we got
nine different types of reefer this is
over oh no this is filled to the brim
look at that [__] [__] there
that's the no label we got some classic
og killing you [__] and we even
threw us at Eve in the mix tonight
Philippe a little [__] what is this
fine Barry look at this [__] Oh muchas
muchas dhama lucious you understand me
that means you're gonna [__] die and
[__] coward whatever that language is
anyone here you go BAM
no hummus we got some stars we got some
liquid acid I got a couple of stars of
molds on them and we got these
chocolate-covered strawberries
give one of these to your grandpa huh
grandpa be [__] up you can steal his
keys doing it'll [__] you off for an
hour too
[Music]
let's like a warm-up please second
aperitif
I missed you [__]
[Music]
noises like that buffet
where's these [__] stars at oh these
are the good ones right here
[Music]
there is a double of a Big Mac
like a good boy you said saying how to
respect for the church or what's
happened now
a Big Mac fully two more Big Macs here
there you go don't worry hit the floor
it's good for you put a little dirt in
your lungs yeah I'm saying [__]
and we're gonna make some room for the
moon boss always remember when you're
inhaling THC plenty of water that's a
tip from uncle Joey that's the god of
these stars that that's alright so let
it's like he's good it's like eating
[__]
you always get some hair in your mouth
no big deal right or wrong everybody
gets pissed off when they eat a sandwich
in this hand their food what about when
you like that [__] little loose
[__] hairs that look like tentacles
and [__] and you get one caught one of
your teeth give me a one else thing hey
never
you ain't [__] right you understandable
anyway that's a complete different
periscope better right now it's the
church what's happening now you fat
[__]
anyway what's Joey what which with the
chitchat and I'm saying Joey listen
enough is enough
but up a bomb fell upon brother before
are you [__] nuts or what this is
Jimmy coming at you sicker 75 and his
[__] strongest whispers [__]
[Music]
I thought jobs are taking a deep
psychological torture chamber clay this
is like going to Rambo 2 or something
like that and get stuck with those
Vietnam vets in the cage anyway we go
bat bat bat bat bat bat bat my back my
back my back
better than are you [__] nuts or what
what you want to shoot a number two bag
a train
[Music]
rayful bungholio watch the over there he
stars with sad face on Lee so we'll
[__] around he's in Vegas all weekend
holding hands playing love of birds we
got time for that [__] we're going deep
until murky waters you can't let those
emotions [__] up cloud your judgment and
I'm saying you got to be a savage at all
times and [__] who gives a [__]
everybody loves but you can't get soft
on me and shaking I'm saying yeah you
concept no softness here with your
little Lambo breathe you've got ten
stars to Vegas unit train married it
[Music]
I'll push I bought back a few [__]
inches what do you think about that [__]
Lee's ready for a bungalow so dubonnet's
little dubonnet's with the moon ball in
conjunction with taking this to the next
level tonight has been no training here
since Wednesday at last week we got to
get back to basics
scissor sweet kicks weeks
[__] clothes college chokes arm bars
basics you understand no [__] crazy
special things go on script and there
you are taking the ass by 10 black guy
you'll need that you're like oh [__]
uncle are you [__] listen to me
tell your grandmother's stay out of your
room tonight cuz we're gonna break it
take out the guy check out the guy check
out the guy I got a gun are you [__]
kidding me where the [__] you think
Metallica gotta come you be saying back
to me hey here's what all these [__]
people got destruction but be stupid
what's up dog please over there going
leaves over there sitting egg on what
the [__] is going on my life
[Music]
4:5 is closed in ten to five devices can
you imagine you anything today ten to
five the next three [__] weeks four
five ten to five [__] I don't have to
go to the airport folks at under 15 so I
don't give a Frenchman spunk and ain't
got nothing to do with me yeah which one
you want to do you want to do that but
that's cousin let's go with debt then we
go [__] fleet training look at
them looking sharp tonight a couple
spots but not enough [__] oh they have
espresso machines on every floor I know
I didn't see that but we barely know
they were so and I said every one piece
of cake
and brought waters every night it was
beautiful they turned you down
yeah why is it oh you wanted it yet Oh
tuck you in bed
that's the one leak that's the one don't
[__] around
that's the one that's the one Venezuela
do it for the hot dog hot days off
that's the one
[Music]
to a place really got I'll just
we're going deep in this [__] time
who's that chocolate who said chocolate
it's time for Mumbai all that fresh I
could smell the foot odor embracing the
baggage I think they make these with
their feet see I take a second I sky
opens up for you ah no problem
violence or make-believe is not even
there like that don't make don't get the
press you get the flesh
[Music]
I need a stunt double the 80s from
get some water quick little bit little
bit to do some more quick now that's it
that's it that's it
it's the first batch he's gotta beat
than three pieces all right look at you
leave your savage see that you're
melting down with some water nobody gets
their [__] feelings hurt like this oh
[__] well well well oh listen you wanna
hang out at the church this be witnesses
yeah I'm saying you want to join the
electrician's Union
you gotta gonna be an algebra and a high
school diploma same thing applies here
you want to come to these doors you
gotta have prerequisites you gotta have
references then the Stampede people
gotta know the [__] you are you big
places you take two three fights to the
trunk and you down it with water
look at you you're savvy you have the
same determination as John Jones for a
second you look like dad caught me after
the fight now you're looking like John
Joe
[Music]
and she said do you wanna
don't you want cupcake cupcake okay see
that's it look three points not easy
it's really easy to be in the Voodoo
Lounge
we don't peel you a little bit let some
saliva to it and that's it
get down it and it goes into your system
Oh Oh baby dance
who's that bondage I've been telling you
for years
listen the Olympics is coming to LA 2028
and we're gonna have a bong hit [__]
this by that time I'm gonna have three
gold medal [__] bong an expert's if
you wanna be one send me your resume
we'll get to work the class starts
December 1st ready in the Buddha lounge
three nights a week
[Music]
there we go don't forget Saturday night
the Ice House working out with uncle
Joey
on the Saturday 15 bucks you're in at
7:30 yeah there by 9:30 do whatever the
[__] you want go [__] the race cars
against Chinese people I don't give a
[__] get this family you know I give a
[__] about here we go
[Music]
do it anyway oh [__] legally like
nothing see you like that John Jones
left before you were looking all for me
it up you will [__] crying yet TZ and
now looking just a little funk it's just
us
don't forget youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz that's the place to be and about 15
minutes when we get this party started
[Music]
we saved themselves and you
oh [__]
[Music]
with all your mind ready let's do this
[__]
[Music]
you're thinking that's for your life for
your life for your life are you [__]
nuts
buh-buh-buh listen are you [__] nuts
if you got listen if you got volumes
take them cuz we're going into a
psychological [__] [__] Nadeau
tonight look at lead companies deck
those spots yet shuffle them to death
give me 15 here we go
are you kiddin Lister Jimmy but now now
are you [__]
[Music]
pop goes the weasel
why did I get water myself in case
that's how we're doing that's a nice
night so beautiful [__] night and the
best part about the night is you're here
[__] here we go
we'll shut behind me here sprinkle
swampland same same thing sake hanging I
was creepy whatever the [__] laughs
right who gives a [__] whatever show
that lands it I'm saying anyway who's
ready for a pilot
oh [__] put your hand down stupid
[Music]
not so white
it's a [__] fire in here tonight any
minute now the fireman so to kick that
[__] doors I don't give a [__]
understanding the mula [__] anyway I'm
happy you're here you know I've missed
you [__] for your life
[Music]
Lee's got his resume down zipper please
like I can't take this you know we're
just trying to have a good time here
there's no weapons here there's no
cocaine here there's no syringes
there's no steroids it's just two fat
[__] having a good time with you people
the church family who's got it better
than you you understand there's no
restrictions here there's no language
barriers we promote nothing we ain't
telling you nothing
you know we're doing we're just two fat
[__] getting on that's it either in
yeah I'm hoping that you get night at
the house with us but if you're not a
ain't matters you know meet them I'm an
easygoing guy I don't get sleep I sleep
[__] the kids all right I'm healthy I
had dinner tonight and a protein shake
up with the jujitsu what I was gonna fat
[__] ass boy that's it I wake up in the
morning go thank you Lord forgive me
another day to let these [__]
suck my nuts because I don't give a [__]
it's a state of mind you understand and
when you get there you'll know it you go
home [__] I'm there now it's perfect now
I'm doing good things because I took the
stick out of my [__] ass boy you're
right you think don't think
don't think that's what always [__] met
up don't thank me just do like Nike just
do it shut the [__] up I don't want to
hear give it took like a chick at a bar
and you wanna suck you wonder like suck
your dick but she gives you an ear
beatin about the fusion which he wants
to do and she's saving up cuz she's
waiting for a bus anyway just do it he's
going to [__] slowly I'm saying he's
going to goddamn slowly a bomb hit is a
[__] it's like a it's like a sword
you could do a thousand things with it
people just don't know they don't wanna
know
here we go concepts one of my all-time
favorite Zeppelin songs T for [__] 1
or P for two one of those ain't good
with names alright if I treat teens for
myself earlier here we go are you
[__] kidding me I was on the zoom bar
for [__] this long hey we got to do
another bong another respect wheeler
from me I didn't write the rules respect
is respect but it's time to do a bong
hit you don't ask questions this law
demands respect
understand me likee grandfatherly 1 he
fought in Korea right he demands respect
same thing respect for myself for this
[__] Jam I don't know what else I
don't know if they stole I got nothing
to do with me I ain't no [__]
detective all I'm telling you is you
want to see the devil this way starts
all right if you're 13 take notes then
get the [__] out of here here we go
[Music]
take notes [__] on fire tonight just
don't happen a lot when Confucius shows
up the Cuban Confucius but we're done
understand we're here with quick
hudsucker get emotional [__]
I've got 24 just what's in it oh [__]
come put something that's how we do it
here this ain't no Museum of reefer
the reef is here to be smoked you want
us look at we go to high tides [__] who
said stars let loose and liquid acid on
a Monday on some raisins who the [__]
you think you're dealing with I can't
believe this afternoon put a couple of
times
[Music]
a minute seems like a lifetime that's
right when you're in County Jail I mean
it seems like a lifetime you're
surrounded by black people don't the
[__] to do you're like what the [__]
played to deserve this [__] I'm only an
MLK Boulevard and I live up and [__]
and see no I'm saying anyway you know
uncle Joey loves you here is a good time
nobody gets their feelings hurt if you
came to the show it's the Borgata
you're a bad [__] we had a great
time you [__] fed me fire
that's why I love you come suck it next
stop Saturday night
ice house and after that San Francisco
punchline tickets almost gone myself and
beam down Rizzy what are you [__]
nuts or what youtube.com slash seats
last Joey dish that's the place to be
tonight I don't know about tomorrow I
don't know about Thursday I'm about
[__] Friday tonight right now you
want to be with you uncle Joey let
youtube.com / c / Joey did show me
eyeballs dead dog
when you get eyeballs like that you take
a picture and you send it on Twitter I'm
gonna see the veins in your [__]
eyeballs blow it up and you'll win a
free weekend for to the [__] in the
booth to Lance
there's no hotel you got sleep in the
lounge here that's the bomb concert here
we go
[Music]
I almost went under there the devil
almost had me here he comes again
[Music]
youtube.com slash ceaseless Joey Diaz
[__] I see in ten minutes
[Music]